for centuries
it looked as if religion was trying to
tell us facts
about the world and just got things a
bit wrong
for example how old the earth was it
claimed 4 000 years old
or how many sons there were in the
universe it claimed
one but in reality religion was never
really interested
in doing the sorts of things that
science does
it might have thrown off the odd theory
but at heart it cared about a mission
altogether different
it wanted to tell us stories to make
life
feel more bearable it was interested in
giving us something to hold on to
that could help us to make it through to
the next day
at the same time science properly viewed
has never been the enemy of spiritual
enrichment
it can yield ideas every bit as
consoling
and inspiring as those found in religion
we can usefully look to science for the
sort of ideas
that we used to seek in religion here
are four
big consoling ideas that can be found
in science firstly perspective
we are at permanent risk in the
conditions of modern life
of losing perspective that is of making
more of our troubles and fears than is
good for
us one of the great benefits of science
is that it can help us to feel small
science teaches us that our galaxy the
milky way
has approximately 100 billion stars in
it
that there are 10 billion galaxies in
the observable universe
each of which contains an average of a
hundred billion stars
which means that there are around a
billion trillion stars out there
when we lose perspective as we
invariably do
in the course of pretty much every day
in the frenetic city
we should spend a few moments with a
photograph
from the hubble telescope and remember
that we are
in a glorious and redemptive way what we
always feared nothing
secondly all is vanity
many of our efforts are designed to
perpetuate ourselves in time we strive
to live on through our work
and to make something more enduring than
our biological selves
to release us from this exhausting and
vainglorious folly
religions used to kindly remind us in
the words of ecclesiastes
that all is vanity science offers us
a yet more powerful expression of this
biblical concept
the second law of thermodynamics
this states that the tendency of all
systems of which the universe is one
is to dissipate energy over time until
it reaches
a state of complete rest given a
sufficient span
our universe and its superclusters of
galaxies will all collapse
and we will enter what scientists call a
dark era
in which after so much excitement
individual and cosmic
nothing will remain except for a dilute
quiet
gas of photons and leptons the situation
is no better closer to home
in about four billion years when the sun
runs out of hydrogen
it will become a red giant star possibly
expanding as far as mars
at which point it will absorb and
destroy earth
to repeat the point but this time with
nasa's help
all truly is vanity
thirdly forgiveness it's often tempting
to lose our temper with ourselves and
our fellow humans
why can't we be more reasonable why are
we so prejudiced
why are we so prone to anxiety why do we
eat so much why are we so interested in
pornography
it's equally tempting to search for
explanations that emphasize our
villainous natures and then to harshly
condemn
our lack of self-command we end up
disgusted with ourselves and
judgmental towards others but science
arguably more effectively than religion
can teach us the art of forgiveness
and liberate us from our urge to
criticize
of course we are less than ideally
adapted to the civilized and
complex lives we aspire to lead we've
had
very little time to do anything else
science tells us that we appeared in
more or less our current form
in africa two hundred thousand years ago
for most of this time we lived in small
groups
we foraged we grunted we didn't wait for
others to stop
talking we fought constantly and we were
terrified
of everything the time since the birth
of jesus
comprises one percent of our history
the last 250 years the period since we
became urbanized and began
living with technology encompasses a
mere
naught point one percent naturally
therefore
most of our impulses are going to be
better suited to more basic conditions
it's a miracle frankly that we ever
manage to be polite
to explain our feelings or to see it
from another's point of view
we are from the vantage point of science
doing
extremely well indeed evolutionary
history
teaches us that humans should be a lot
worse than they are
the wonder isn't in the end that we're
so uncivilized
but that we ever even manage now and
then to have
a few moments of civilization
fourthly our existence
science is supremely capable of
nurturing feelings of gratitude
because of a basic truth about the way
gratitude
works it stems from an awareness
of how much more awful things might have
been
and here when it comes to our life on
the planet
science tells us that we have so much to
be grateful for
for example we can be grateful that 13.8
billion years ago
something smaller than an electron chose
to swell
within a fraction of a second like an
expanding balloon
into a zone permeated with energy 93
billion light years in size
that we now clumsily call the universe
we can be grateful that some of the
energy from this swift expansion
was able to coagulate into particles
which group together to form light atoms
of
hydrogen lithium and helium which then
assembled into galaxies
which gave birth to stars inside whose
molten burning cores
all the elements necessary for the
nucleic acids essential to life
were forged we can be grateful that
gravity
drew these stars together to create
galaxies 100 billion of them
including fortuitously the milky way a
small corner of the universe containing
just
400 billion stars in which our sun was
born
out of a giant spinning cloud of dust
and gas
4.5 billion years ago we can be grateful
that around the same time
swarms of debris collided to form our
earth
a lava-washed uninhabitable rock that
gravity happened to throw into orbit
as the third planet from the sun the
exact right distance for life to develop
we can be grateful that another planet
thea collided with earth
gifting us our moon which slowed the
earth's rotation
stabilized atmospheric conditions and
created the 24-hour day
and caused the earth to tilt forming the
seasons
we can be grateful that ice particles
left over from the collisions of
hundreds of comets melted water vapor
condensed
and oceans were formed we can be
grateful that comet collisions delivered
another chance cosmic gift
the essential components of life and dna
like ribose carbon dioxide ethanol
amino acids and phosphorus we can be
grateful that underwater hot springs
release the right amount of energy in
the right mix of chemicals
to allow the first single cell organisms
to form
four billion years ago we can be
grateful that the earth's toxic
atmosphere of
methane and carbon dioxide slowly became
sweetened by the release of oxygen
from cyanobacteria the first creatures
to photosynthesize
and gradually oxygenated 85 percent of
the atmosphere
we can be grateful that an asteroid 15
kilometers wide
happened to hit earth 65.5 million years
ago
and destroyed most terrestrial organisms
including those
non-avian dinosaurs but created ideal
conditions
in which small furry mammals our close
ancestors
were able to thrive with less
competition we can be grateful that your
genes
managed to pass safely through an
unbroken 10
000 generation chain despite the best
efforts of cyclones predators and
a constant barrage of viruses and we can
be grateful
that an average fertile woman will have
a hundred thousand eggs
and a man will produce a trillion sperm
each of these
very different but that nevertheless you
have managed to emerge from all the
options
just as you are and to all this as they
used to say in the churches
one might cry or whisper hallelujah
there is enough in science to give birth
to 20 religions
so much to worship to be awed by and to
be consoled through
things like dark matter string theory or
quantum wave functions
the curse of the modern world is not to
have invented science
it's not yet to have understood all the
amazing things
one might still do with it at the school
of life we run regular virtual classes
for adults
these mini life courses cover such
topics as making relationships work
overcoming anger and anxiety career
guidance
finding meaning and purpose in life and
using culture as a therapeutic
tool click the link on screen now to
learn more